Let's start today with an update on how the
pandemic is going in the United States and
around the world, this is probably the least
good update that we've had in a couple of
months.
But it does require some thought and some
explanation and there's some details to understand.
So the top line, like the bad number, the
number going in the wrong direction is cases.
Cases per day in the United States and around
the world are now climbing once again.
And after more than two months of declines
and significant declines for much of that
to two and a half month period, average daily
cases are again ticking up not by that much,
but from a low of about 55000 new cases a
day in the United States, now up about five
percent to 58000 cases per day.
Remember context.
These are numbers many in twenty twenty thought
we would never get to.
We blew past them all the way up to two hundred
and fifty five thousand cases per day came
back down and now we're back up from 55000
to 58000.
What is driving this?
We're vaccinating we're vaccinating millions
per day at this point and we'll look at those
numbers.
How is it that cases are again going up?
A couple of different things going on.
One is that in some states, the more contagious
British variant known as B one one seven is
becoming more widespread.
Now, remember that the vaccines work really
well against B one one seven, but among unvaccinated
people, it's going to spread more.
That's exactly what is happening, for example,
in Michigan, Michigan is a place where B one
one seven is becoming more widespread as the
variant of of dominance.
And Michigan's cases aren't just ticking up
slightly.
They're skyrocketing primarily again among
unvaccinated people.
Michigan cases are up 250 percent from a recent
low.
So the other aspect of this is, is more of
a sort of I guess you'd call it a psychological
aspect in a sense, as people learn about vaccination
and they hear that people are getting vaccinated
and they hear that cases are coming down,
some people choose to behave less safely.
And there's an analogy here to something that
traffic engineers deal with.
When traffic engineers look at a stretch of
highway, a road, for example, that has a lot
of traffic and they say we need more lanes
in order to better accommodate traffic, they
will start a project to widen the road.
And of course, people learn about the fact
that the road is going to be widened and will
have more capacity.
And often what happens is that by the time
that the road is widened, increasing capacity,
more people, because they have heard, hey,
this road will have more capacity, so traffic
will go down, more people choose to use the
road.
And so by the time that the road is done,
you have more capacity.
But traffic is moving just as slowly because
more people are choosing to use the road.
Similarly, we are seeing spring breakers in
Florida states rolling back all guidelines,
et cetera, as cases started to come down because
vaccination was going up and the seasonality
effect, more people are behaving less, less
responsibly, less safely, I guess we would
say.
And thus we are starting to see cases tick
back up.
Now, despite cases going up.
The good news is that deaths continue to decline
for now.
As we know at this point, deaths lag cases
by about three weeks.
We're already three weeks out from cases leveling
deaths continue to decline from their peak
of about nearly 3500 a day towards the middle
to end of January, now down to about a thousand
deaths a day.
That is a decline of 70 percent.
But the decline, the rate of decline is slowing
down.
And one signal that might not bode so well
is in terms of people going into the hospital.
New hospitalizations have also continued down,
but the rate of decline is slowing down significantly.
So this is a crucial period of about, I would
say, two to three months is what most of the
epidemiologists say.
It's a battle of vaccination versus variance.
And we have very good data about how good
the vaccines are.
I read yesterday a study which tracked California
health care workers after being vaccinated.
And what the study found was that the fully
vaccinated health care workers, meaning 14
days out from dose number two, something like
zero point zero five percent, became infected.
This is a group that's highly exposed, working
in health care settings around unvaccinated
sick patients, very low rate of contagion
among those who are vaccinated.
So that's the good news.
Vaccinations now averaging right around two
point five million doses per day, that's a
combination of two dose vaccines and a single
dose.
Johnson and Johnson total two point five million
doses per day.
That number should continue to grow.
It appears that it is going to continue to
grow.
But this is not a good time to start going
crazy the way we've seen spring breakers do
in Florida.
So super zoomed out, vaccinations up, deaths
down.
That's good.
Medium term hospitalizations leveling out,
not declining that quickly lately.
Cases up and vaccine distribution in much
of the world, not good.
And ultimately, I mean, to really get back
to normal as a global village, for lack of
a better term, other countries are going to
need to do well on vaccination.
There are countries not expected to get significant
access to vaccines until 2023, maybe wouldn't
even fully vaccinate until 2024.
Who knows what variants will be on two by
then.
So this is a bigger issue.
Now, we're starting to hear, you know, more
about a vaccine equity and countries like
the U.S. and the U.K. hoarding vaccines and
different issues.
As I've said before, I think it's perfectly
natural that countries would try to vaccinate
their own people first.
But there is no question that until there
is more vaccine distribution globally, we
are not going to be able to say that we have
we have dealt with the pandemic, but let's
keep vaccinating.
All you can do here in the US is when you
can get a vaccine, get one.
That's what you can do